um it's hard to get that competition mode mindset when it's just like you in just such a small space
yeah like it's like so hard to like yeah you know what i mean right so like i said some stuff in the
conference like how like it's like um when you're in competition you see your coaches your teammates
your even your competitors right so you feel like this pressure yeah so it's like like
it's like that feeling kind of boosts your competition mode right like i didn't really
feel that here yeah yeah like of course yes that's basically like when i grow up as a thing
that's great that's super great yeah we we are not able to do this in a competition
yeah so it's like really hard right now but i really get what you mean yeah but it's um
we we we do what we think we think
yeah no this is like this is great this is great
yeah um yeah i think um we might be able to do kind of a data collection during competitions
but you have to sort that one out with everything yeah yeah you're gonna be like no no we can't
no i guess yes of course because you also need to be focused at that specific time you cannot
be yeah if you're setting up all this you're setting up all that yeah like it's yeah
it's so much fun though no like actually like it was like very unique experience like
i wouldn't i wouldn't get this experience anywhere else it's so nice to hear we also
have your artery so oh shoot was i like was i fly we we have we did not see the data yet
so
oh my gosh that was great um you'd have to talk to them about it again so yeah that's
all right
yes yeah because i asked them and they're like oh i won't make me sign up for anything like that
i'm like oh no they are signed up for next week yeah i'll ask them how they did yeah
that was just great i can't wait to show you your big freestyle stuff
but i just did like two like three like three different things like it wasn't even
crazy like it was like basic like white belt i did like a 360 ground up stick or something
okay
maybe you have more frames we only have 17 slots for march so just four more then
i'm gonna forward you the link yeah
no
yeah maybe i could send it to someone for yeah i don't know who knows
but hope it benefits from a report kind of in a video kind of thing so
like it doesn't no one really thinks of this so i don't know i guess it would be unique for anyone
yeah yeah i'm gonna send you the link okay send it to them so they can also try
all right i wish i could show you right away what it looks like
how long do you think the thing probably a few weeks a few weeks yeah so like by the end of this
month you have an idea what it looks like no i'm not able to explain yeah i'll send it to you i'll
send it to you okay okay mom just sleep on it yo i might forget and then suddenly i get an email yes
yes it was nice meeting you guys yeah oh my gosh you're so amazing thank you thank you i'm not
oh my gosh, you're so amazing. Thank you. Thank you. I'm not.
Thank you. I'm not.
All right.